[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBIN BROWN: So we're here to
answer questions about Anthos.
We have some pretty senior
software engineers and product
managers up on the stage.
Just like it was
stated before, we
want this to be very
fluid and interactive,
so definitely queue up if you
have those live questions.
But to start off, I'm
going to introduce myself
and then we'll go down the line.
I'm Robin Brown.
I'm in the professional
services organization.
I'm the Global Practice Lead
of Application Development.
I sit in Chicago.
So it's great to be
out here in California
and meeting with all
of our customers.
So how about you guys introduce
yourself and then maybe
add a song that you
think represents Anthos.
SVEN MAWSON: OK, me first?
ROBIN BROWN: Yeah.
SVEN MAWSON: All right.
So, hey, everyone.
I'm Sven.
I'm one of the founders
of Istio and I also
work on Cloud Service
Mesh at Google and Anthos,
which Cloud Service
Mesh is part of.
I've been at Google
actually for like 13 years,
worked on a bunch of
internal structure.
This is kind of our first big
push to have external products.
It's pretty awesome.
The song that I
think comes to mind--
and I'm not entirely
sure why this is--
but "Thunderstruck" by AC/DC.
Maybe just because
that's how I think
people feel when
they learn about all
that Anthos will do for them.
Yeah, there you go.
Michael?
MICHAEL RUBIN: Hello.
My name is Michael Rubin.
I am the dev lead of
GKE On Prem, which
means all the engineering
bits and pieces are
the games I get to play with.
And I also work a lot
in GKE and Cloud 2.
The music I guess that
makes sense to me is--
does anyone know the
Squirrel Nut Zippers?
They're sort of
loud, cacophonous
music, lots of jazz.
And they have a song
called "The Afterlife."
We've been playing that song
a lot to sort of late nights
occasionally working
and beating to the drums
and sort of having lots of fun.
And the other one
I'm going to add in
is Tom Petty's got one called
"Something Good's Coming."
I don't know if
anyone knows that one.
It's not one of his big hits.
It's kind of that
quiet song that you
play when it's late at
night and nothing's working
and you need to make it work.
And it basically brings
me a lot of peace
and it's helped some
other people, too.
Thanks.
DAN CIRULI: I'm Dan Ciruli.
I'm a product manager.
I work on the service
mesh technology, so
Istio, Cloud Service Mesh, and
of course its role in Anthos.
I'm going to start
with a prediction
that Michael will give two
answers to every question.
And the song that I will go
with is a Foo Fighters song
called "Learn to Fly"
because I think people are
going to do that with Anthos.
Metaphorically
speaking, of course.
ROBIN BROWN: So coming from
the field with all of our field
implementation, security
is a huge concern,
and rightfully so.
What sort of added benefits
does Anthos offer our customers
from a security perspective?
SVEN MAWSON: So I can take
that from sort of the service
communication aspect.
Michael can maybe answer
on the containerization.
So security actually
is one of the big focus
areas of Istio as a whole and
sort of by extension Cloud
Service Mesh.
So we want to make it really,
really simple for people
to secure all of
their communication.
Like, everything should
be encrypted in transit.
You shouldn't have
to worry about it.
Everything should be safe.
You should limit
your blast radius,
like zero trust networks.
All of that realm of just
making security something you
don't have to
worry about anymore
that is just taken
care of for you.
I think Anthos is really
going to provide that.
It takes care of a lot of
the sort of nitty-gritty
of making sure all that works,
making sure fees are rotated,
certs are rotated
in the right time,
that things revoke
if they need to be,
make it all happen the
way that it should.
And then we actually give
you controls on top of that
so you can say, like, hey,
only this thing should
be able to talk to that thing.
Only this application
should talk to this service.
And that lets you
actually control
things at a much
better way than you
would with a typical
network firewalls, right?
Like, you're not
saying, this IP address
is connected to that IP address.
You don't have to go mess
with IP tables rules.
You just say, this can talk
to that, and that's it.
And that's how
Google has actually
been running things for
15 plus years internally.
And it works
really, really well.
And I think everyone's
going to really like that.
MICHAEL RUBIN: Dan
knows me too well.
We've been working
together a while.
I have two answers to this.
I'm not really sure I like
you that much right now.
So I kind of bundle security
in sort of two categories.
There's the whiz bang deep
understanding security.
I think if you take a
look at a lot of the day
zero exploits, a lot
of them were sort
of finder addressed by Google.
You know, if you
want to have fun,
check out the work by
Michelle Au or Tim Allclair.
A lot of this stuff
got featured in LWN.
And you can see there's a lot
of deep understanding of what's
really going on in this
new space with containers
and security.
What's nice is that with
Anthos, when these things are
happening, it's
really hard to keep
track of microservice
security and what's
going on in that barrier
between containers in the OS.
We have an integrated
solution that we
take care of that for the user.
Keeping track of your operating
system, your container
technology, your Kubernetes,
and what happened in the latest
release--
it's hard.
It's very hard to keep on track.
And we have that expertise.
You don't have to
worry about it.
The other part is kind of
a more boring part, which
is keeping things up to date.
It's not easy to do
with open source.
And staying on top
of the latest CDEs,
knowing which ones
are worthy of upgrade
and which ones aren't,
it's something else
that Anthos is about.
So we've started and designed
it from the beginning
to think about upgradability and
doing that all the way, again,
down to the stack, with the
operating system, the host OS,
the container OSes, and all
the parts of Kubernetes.
That's the part that's
much more of the grind.
But it's the piece
that you really
want to outsource
because you just do.
That's about it.
I don't know if we're going
to go through everybody.
Yeah, I hate those
panels where everyone
says how they feel
today and then
you get bored by
the last person.
And Dan, you nailed me too much.
So I'm going to just
go back to Robin.
Questions from the audience?
I don't know.
ROBIN BROWN: Raise your hand
if you're a dev ops person
or you work with
your CI/CD pipeline.
We have a few in the crowd.
So maybe Dan or Mike--
SVEN MAWSON: What's
the question?
ROBIN BROWN: Can
you talk to kind
of the value statement of
CI/CD or some of the benefits
that we're incorporating to
kind of meet the customer where
they're at, so instead of adding
overhead burden to maintaining
another CI/CD pipeline,
kind of the incorporation
into their
pre-existing pipeline?
DAN CIRULI: So I gave
a talk earlier today.
Did anyone attend my
talk earlier today.
This will be a
refresher for you.
But for everybody
else, is this is new.
This customer is not
using Anthos yet,
but they are using the
different components.
They're using GKE.
They're using Istio.
And in the last six months have
migrated about 186 services
from an on-prem VM based cluster
to a GKE cluster using Istio.
And what's beautiful
is that they
didn't change their
developer experiences at all.
They have a very
good CI/CD pipeline.
And they changed the output
of that CI/CD pipeline, which
used to compile a
jar, spin up a VM,
and then deploy
that jar to the VM.
Now instead, their developers
still use the same CI/CD,
but they've modified
their pipeline
so it produces a container
and it deploys that container
into GKE.
And the beauty of what they
did was that they already--
they were disciplined enough
to already not have developers
who are off, you know,
SSH-ing into hosts
to get things involved.
They had done some automation.
And when they adopted, kind of
changed the platform completely
underneath, it didn't
affect their developers.
And that's been a big deal.
They are now multilingual,
where they could only
handle jars before.
Now the developers use
the appropriate language
for the appropriate tool.
They have better insight than
ever into their application
and how it's running.
But what would enable that whole
thing was a good, robust CI/CD
pipeline.
ROBIN BROWN: So what we're
hearing a lot from customers
across the board is
introducing another technology,
if you think about
the change for people
process and tools or technology,
we're offering new technology.
We're offering new processes.
What do we do about
the people aspect?
How does tomorrow
look for customers
that are adopting this
[INAUDIBLE] change?
MICHAEL RUBIN: You want to
take incoming questions first
before we--
because we've got a list here.
Or do you want to--
ROBIN BROWN: We have
no one queued up.
MICHAEL RUBIN: We have a queue?
ROBIN BROWN: We don't
have anyone queued up.
MICHAEL RUBIN: OK.
So like, while you're in
the audience right now--
SVEN MAWSON: These two
people with red jackets--
MICHAEL RUBIN: Just to let
you know, the people here,
like Dan, Sven,
myself, we have handled
ugly situations with customers--
maybe not always as well
as we want.
But we've worked and
journeyed with the customer.
Please feel free to ask
what's on your mind.
And I don't think we'd have
the most successful experience
right now if you just
hear us tell you a one way
conversation.
If we have anybody with
some thoughts or even
some humdingers that
they think are hard,
you know, please feel free.
That's fine.
That's what we're
here for right now.
And hopefully we'll
be doing this here.
And if you don't want
to do it right now,
we'll be at the booth later
if you want to hit us.
Someone's got his hand up.
Wonderful.
ROBIN BROWN: Oh, there we go.
Brave soul.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: Hey, thank you.
And I'll start the ball rolling.
So we've got a hybrid cloud
strategy where I work.
We're just about to start with
Google, but we've got Azure.
We've got IBM Cloud.
Tell me a little
bit more about how
Anthos is going to help me
deploy to all three clouds
and avoid the
fragmentation that kind of
goes on if you don't have
something like Anthos.
MICHAEL RUBIN: So first
time, I think the question
that you asked,
just to restate it
for people who maybe
didn't hear it, too,
is that you have an environment
right now that Azure, IBM,
and maybe Google, too--
you're just about to
start Google, how do you
keep consistency
among these three
different environments that
have a very different stack?
So there is no silver
bullet to anything.
And I'm not going
to pretend there is.
It depends on where you
are in your journey.
If you are very container and
Kubernetes ready right now,
the neat thing
about Anthos today
is that you can deploy
Kubernetes across them
and have a consistent
interface and API
that will be able
to abstract out
a whole bunch of the components
in these environments.
I mean, that's one of the
big values of Kubernetes
that you can manage your
hardware environment
and your software
environment lifecycle
in a consistent way with
some YAML as opposed
to actually making code changes.
What's also nice about
what we're doing here
with Anthos is that it
allows you to-- we're
providing tools to actually
do rollout configuration
and other items that
are, again, consistent.
Like, consistency
and choice is really
some of the big
points behind Anthos.
So I encourage everyone--
there's this thing we
haven't talked about
as much, I think,
in the keynotes
and other areas--
Anthos config management--
which is basically
how do we use Git,
leverage that in YAML
to allow you to handle
all these environments
and resources at different
levels, keep it straight,
and then deploy it selectively.
So I could go and
talk about this
forever because it's a
complicated and complex
problem.
But if you take a look
at the offering-- sorry.
If you take a look
at the offering
you should be able to see that
the consistency of the API
and the goals of making sure
that we are abstracting away
multi cloud--
our identity story rests
quite heavily on OIDC--
as opposed to deeply
diving into per environment
specific APIs is the
thrust and the theme
behind the technology.
Does that answer your question?
OK.
For those not
seeing it, he's kind
of nodding like he
bought it, which is good.
DAN CIRULI: You have
something to add?
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah.
I was going add something.
I don't know.
DAN CIRULI: So
this is what I want
to say is that today I
heard someone on stage
say with Anthos you can finally
write once and run anywhere.
And any developer says, well,
I can write code and run it
anywhere today, right?
I can take Python.
And Python runs
the same at Google
as it does at Azure as
it does at IBM, right?
The thing is that everything
around that running code, how
you network to it,
how you authenticate,
all of that is very
different at IBM
and in Azure and in Google
and on your on prem.
And the idea with
Anthos is making
all of that consistent so
that everything around that
can be the same no
matter whether you're
deploying to Google or to
IBM or Azure or Amazon.
And it's that
consistency that I think
we're helping to give you.
SVEN MAWSON: I was just going
to add that I think, actually,
Anthos also can help you
with moving things around
between your different
environments, too.
So if you install Anthos
in all the environments
and it's really easy to spin up
something in a different place,
see how it performs, route 1%,
10%, whatever amount of traffic
to it, compare things, do
all that kind of stuff,
and you can actually
seamlessly move things around
between clouds, between
Kubernetes and VMs,
wherever you want,
without anything else
having to know about it.
So that's really useful.
MICHAEL RUBIN: I like that one.
Is there another?
I mean, does anyone have
anything on their mind,
you know, worse
than [INAUDIBLE]..
That's fine.
I know Robin's got more, but--
I'm sorry, you sir?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I just wondered if there was
any particular CD component
that you're proposing.
MICHAEL RUBIN: Can you
get closer to the mic?
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sorry.
Apologies.
Just wondered if there's
a particular CD tool
you're proposing in Anthos.
Is it Spinnaker, for instance?
MICHAEL RUBIN: Oh, what is--
ROBIN BROWN: Continuous.
SVEN MAWSON: Is
there a CD system
that's sort of built into Anthos
or proposed to use with Anthos?
ROBIN BROWN: The marketplace?
MICHAEL RUBIN:
Continuous deployment.
So the continuous
deployment space right now
is in sort of an interesting
transformational pivot point.
And it looks like
for the longest time
Jenkins has been what
people have been using
as an automation structure.
And it's kind of
like the bash script
of being able to handle
sequential events.
And right now as
people are moving
into the cloud, the
elastic nature of the cloud
and the more sophisticated
needs of concurrency
as we scale is creating this
really interesting opportunity,
I think, for all
the technologies.
It's kind of fun
to watch, you know.
What got us all here is
not going to get us there.
And so right now,
Google has not--
we have our opinionated
conversations and technologies
that we're offering.
But at the same point, we
do what I think we do well.
We're trying to make
the space successful.
So there's this thing
out there that I
learned about a few weeks ago
called the Continuous Delivery
Foundation, which is yet
another Linux Foundation
organization that is supposed to
make the open source world look
good and have us
all work together.
And we recently donated
something called techton
to it, which is based, again,
upon the same sort of things
that we believe will
allow us to, like I say,
take things to the next
level, allow us to scale,
and allow us to have a
different API system.
So that's a good
piece of technology
to look at right now.
But that said, Anthos
is very componentizable.
So it will work with Jenkins.
It will work with
other solutions.
And I don't know
if anyone really
has a clear winner for
the next five years
of where the industry and the
conversation is going to go.
But what's nice about
Anthos is you have choice.
You have less risk that
when you take Anthos,
these APIs are flexible enough
that you're not locked in.
And to me, when I'm
building large systems that
are going to last a long
time, that's what's valuable.
So I can sort of hedge
my bets a little bit
and see where I want to
put my cleverness beans.
You're smiling, so again,
I feel like it's working.
Or not.
All right.
ROBIN BROWN: Can you talk
about how you connect
to Jenkins in the marketplace.
SVEN MAWSON: How do you connect
Jenkins to the marketplace.
DAN CIRULI: I still
haven't heard the question.
So I heard how do you connect
Jenkins to a platypus.
ROBIN BROWN: Marketplace.
DAN CIRULI: And
I don't know if--
MICHAEL RUBIN: To
the marketplace.
DAN CIRULI: I don't know
if our marketplace has
APIs that would allow you to do
that in an automated fashion.
I'm not sure.
ROBIN BROWN: It does, yeah.
So we have-- we have
about 15 or 20 or so apps
available in the marketplace.
So Jenkins is one
of those things
that we're leading with as
a premier partner that's
available.
And we have APIs available
through the marketplace.
So if you're already
a Jenkins customer,
you can continue to use Jenkins
via marketplace for Anthos.
Any other live questions?
Live questions?
DAN CIRULI: Anyone?
I guess they did a really
good job in the keynote,
so well that they told everybody
everything they need to know.
How many of you are using
GKE in production today?
Oh, I see.
So it's a small
number of people.
OK, how many of you are using
VMs in production today?
What do the rest of you use?
Are people using
Kubernetes that is not GKE?
It's mostly AS 400
mainframe developers here.
There's some Kubernetes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
ROBIN BROWN: I'd say--
how about this.
So I'm engaged with a lot of
customers across the globe.
And we have kind of
like the entire stack.
And we're talking about
product by product.
But if you really think about
just like the one or two
game changing effects of
the entire stack of Anthos,
what are things that
you would highlight?
SVEN MAWSON: You want me to go?
ROBIN BROWN: Yeah, we can do the
boring like go down the line,
but it's important.
SVEN MAWSON: So actually,
I'll let you guys go.
I'll think about it.
DAN CIRULI: So I'll start
by talking a little bit more
about that customer who
I talked with today.
And they kind of related their
journey to GKE and Istio.
And again, they're
not on Anthos yet,
but they're already
seeing these benefits.
In addition to things like
their spending has gone down,
their resource consumption has
gone down, and they have MTLS,
they have much better
security than they used to,
the real benefit to them is
that they're 350 services.
They used to do a total of
about, I think they said,
400 deployments a year.
Deployments were a big deal.
This year right now, they're on
pace to do 15,000 deployments.
And for them, the difficulty in
doing a deployment-- you know,
many of these teams
were deploying quarterly
in the past.
Now they have people who are--
they're deploying constantly.
And they said that the fiscal
year they're just finishing
is $15,000.
Next year they
think it will be 30.
And so one of the
benefits is moving
to this real microservices
based environment.
You can move very quickly.
And for them, above all else,
that's the biggest thing
they're getting out of it.
SVEN MAWSON: So is it OK if
I go next, and then you go?
So I was actually just
thinking back to something
that Eric Brewer said
in a talk recently when
he was talking about Istio.
So one of the
things Istio does is
it helps you decouple sort
of the development tasks
from the operation tasks.
It might still be the same
person doing them, right,
but they're very distinct.
What Anthos does for you is
take all those operation tasks
and help you automate them.
So you just can focus on that
development part, that sort
of fun part, at least for me.
You don't have to do as
much to do the operations.
You don't have to
manage all the services
and keep them up
and give them SLAs
and all that kind of stuff.
So I think that's
the big game changer
for me is that decoupling
and then automation.
So the more that we can--
the more that we can take
away from sort of the things
that you don't want to be doing
and just automate that, make
it all built into the platform,
make it easy to control
and let you focus
on your business
and what you want
to do, the better.
And that's, I think, a big
part of the Anthos story.
MICHAEL RUBIN:
Businesses now are
pretty much in a race
for software and software
iteration.
So I was surprised.
I was talking to a
tire company and they
said we want to be
a services company.
And I'm like, you sell tires.
They go, no, no, no,
we sell tire services.
And what this really means to
me is they want their software
to iterate and be competitive.
Software to me is
just imagining things.
And what you want
in your company
is the developers to focus on
imagining things that only are
specific to your company, your
applications, and the value
that you can get
out of them to focus
on what your company needs
to do to be successful.
If you have them also spending
a lot of their time managing
and focusing and developing
the infrastructure,
I find it hard to
understand how you're
going to be as competitive.
Someone else out there
may outsource that
or have someone else do that.
And this is what we're trying to
do to provide for the customer.
I met this really
great person once,
a customer, who said I don't
want my engineers tinkering
with Kubernetes or tinkering
with all this infrastructure
over and over and over again.
We want them to come to you
with what needs to be better,
and then work with you
to improve it while they
focus on solving our problems.
And I think that this
sort of partnership
is really what Anthos is about.
And I know it's a little cliche
and a little weird and a little
abstract, but it's
really where do
you want to spend the cleverness
means in your organization?
Where do you want
to have your focus?
And so with Anthos, if
you look at the problems,
it's tackling configuration
management, cluster management,
application lifecycle,
service mesh,
you know, how involved do you
want to be in the open source
management of these
items and how much of it
do you want to leverage others
to shape and focus that work?
ROBIN BROWN: And we
have a live question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So how you configure Anthos?
I mean, by definition,
you said it's YAML?
And like you assume like
for a Rail configuration
it would be like a huge YAML
file or something like that.
I'm curious, like, probably
you have some SDK or something
like that to configure it.
DAN CIRULI: Well, I can talk
about Anthos config management.
So Anthos has--
SVEN MAWSON: Repeat the
question real quick.
DAN CIRULI: So the
question was, Anthos
sounds like there's a
lot of configuration.
Is it a big, huge YAML file?
And in reality, it's
worse than that.
It's many, many huge
YAML files, in reality.
I want to be clear, right?
YAML is one of the great things
about Kubernetes is its API.
But the primary interface
of that API is YAML.
When I see very successful
implementations,
though, they aren't making their
developers go write that YAML.
You know, I see very
successful implementations
where the CI/CD
pipeline itself can
take the intent from
the developer, which
might be a very simple config
file, and express that in YAML.
So in some ways, I think of YAML
as the byte code of the cloud
native foundation, right?
No one writes byte code.
You write in higher
level languages.
And so it may be very well
that you have a simple config
file that says, deploy
me in two regions,
and deploy me with
five replicas.
And what comes out the
other end is some YAML
that goes into the config
management and effects
that change.
One thing that we can do is
we can take the Anthos config
management can make
sure that configuration
is consistent across
your-- if you are running
multiple clusters, that it
can make sure that you have
the correct policies and the
correct YAML, essentially,
in the right places.
So in reality, if you think
about all the different CRDs
that are involved in a
Kubernetes implementation,
the YAML can be daunting.
But in a real
practical application,
you might not need to expose
that to your developers.
And that sounds
kind of outlandish,
but I know customers with very
successful implementations
where that's exactly
what they did was they
abstracted away the
actual YAML itself.
SVEN MAWSON: I do want
to add one thing there,
which is that the
APIs for Anthos
are just the open source
APIs for Kubernetes and Istio
and the other components.
There is not a
proprietary API here,
which means all of your
configuration is portable.
You can spin it all up if
you want to run it yourself.
And all your applications
and configurations
will be portable to that.
So we don't have a
proprietary, you know,
Google developed API that
we're using for all this.
It's just the open source APIs.
MICHAEL RUBIN: The product
Anthos configuration management
takes longer to say than to
appreciate and probably to use.
So there was a demo yesterday
at the multi cloud session.
I encourage you to check it out.
In the middle of that demo
of how to deploy things
across multi cloud, they
had like a 90 second piece
where they used Anthos
configuration management.
And it was really
straightforward.
It was really easy
to see how they
took the various
configuration and then
deployed it selectively.
And honestly, I kind of think
that we're talking about it
in a way that highlights
its importance.
But the ease of use with what
that team put together to me
was surprising.
And when I finally
saw the demo, I
was like, oh, well, this
isn't that big a deal at all.
And so it's worth checking out.
Instead of trying to have
us here convince you,
take a look at that demo.
I know that I talked
to the tech lead.
There's going to be
more demos coming out
about Anthos config management.
And I think it's one of these
things that when you see it,
it's a lot easier to understand
that the problem space doesn't
have to be that hard.
ROBIN BROWN: We have another
live question in the back.
AUDIENCE: I don't
think it's working.
Can you comment on just the
right path to get started?
What's the right way to
train, to learn, to evaluate?
I assume it's not free, so
somehow we have to take--
we have to go from our
production Kubernetes
environment, introduce, prove
it out, and implement it.
So maybe just comment on
what that path looks like.
MICHAEL RUBIN: So I'm really
excited to talk about this
because I think I've had a
lot of learning in this area.
It's really easy to look at
all this open source technology
and get excited about
just the technology.
And I think you leave out two
really important ingredients
or components of the
solution-- people,
and on top of that, the
problem you're trying to solve.
And what I've learned
is that instead
of going from the
bottom up and saying,
what do my VMs look like?
What does my
Kubernetes look like?
What's the footprint I need?
I think it helps a lot
first to understand
that the people you're
trying to solve--
not just your customers,
but your organization--
and what the flow of that
organization is going to be.
I tend to think that
what we're doing here--
we have app developers.
We have cluster administrators
or resource administrators.
Then we have infrastructure
administrators.
And understand their needs.
And then understand
the needs and the shape
of the applications.
And I find that if you don't
do that first, if you instead
focus on all the whiz
bang cool fun toys,
you're going to find that
you may have built something
that feels really good,
but doesn't really
solve your problem.
And I think once you
do that, once you
know the shape of the footprint,
what success looks like,
what your success metrics
look like, not just
in the end solution
of what you write,
but the operating lifecycle
of what you're doing,
I think that helps a lot.
And the last thing is,
what's nice about Anthos--
and I think the
really great thing
that Kubernetes
helps you with is
it embeds the idea of the
lifecycle of your solution
into almost all the APIs.
So it's rarely just
about provisioning.
It's also about
managing and then
decommissioning and operating.
And if you understand the
problem you're solving,
the people you're dealing with,
and all the lifecycle of them
first, I think
you'll start finding
that the technology
pieces almost
fall out of that very easily.
I don't know if that's more--
I can be more
specific, if you want.
SVEN MAWSON: Yeah, so how do
you get started with Anthos?
MICHAEL RUBIN: So if you want
to get started on Anthos--
Go first.
ROBIN BROWN: So
everything that Mike said
you don't have to do alone.
Myself-- and there are actually
quite a few of my team members
in the crowd--
professional services
has been teaming up
with eng NPM very closely over
the last year and a half or so
to really understand
the technology
and frame out what are
the best practices?
What are the gotchas?
What are the pitfalls
going through everything
from the installation
of GKE On Prem
if you want to do an end
on prem installation all
the way through the stack--
config management, CSM
or the service mesh layer,
even looking at things
like Knative and cloud run.
Your entire deployment
pipeline also.
So we're deeply involved
in all of those things
and you don't have
to do it alone.
You can partner
with us and we would
be very willing to do
that journey with you.
MICHAEL RUBIN: And bringing
up the Kubernetes environment
has been happening a lot
faster than the customers have
expected so far.
So again, I don't want to
make a guarantee or a promise
on stage, or even not on stage.
But so far, the customers
have been very, very happy
with how long it
takes from going
from the initial environment to
actually bringing up a cluster
because [INAUDIBLE] is
trained and the software
has been shaped well
by people who've
been doing this for a while.
So getting that cluster up and
going first, maybe starting
with a stateless workload,
and then working from there
based on your
requirements is probably
a good way to get started.
And playing with
configuration management,
I really can't overstate
how you understand that
and involve it in your
workflow early can be helpful.
SPEAKER 1: I have
just one thing to add.
So for those of you that
have a team to train,
we do have a two--
we have two Coursera courses
that are being made available.
So our training team does
work with our technical leads
to roll our
architecting with GKE
for those of you that need
GKE experiences, hands
on experiences.
And this was have
hands-on lab and all.
The second piece is
architecting hybrid with Anthos.
So that will be made
available in a couple months.
So you can look out for
those Coursera courses.
ROBIN BROWN: I
think we have time
for one last live question.
Does anyone have
a live question?
There we go.
So it sounds like
what I've heard from--
so what I've heard
in the keynote was
this is a multi cloud solution.
But we're purely in GCP.
Is it something
that we should be
looking at if we're going
through the whole decomposition
effort?
And what does it really give
us that we should look at?
SVEN MAWSON: So
absolutely yes, right?
So this is about managing
your stuff wherever it is.
If it all happens to be
in GCP already, awesome.
Thank you.
But yeah, it's going to
give you the security.
It's going to give
you the networking.
You know, GKE gives you
great container management.
The Config Manager
portion of Anthos
is still useful if you run
anything more than one cluster.
If you have VMs and
clusters, you should do that.
So yeah, absolutely it's useful,
even if you're just on GCP.
MICHAEL RUBIN: Our
success metric--
I can say that quickly--
is consistency and choice.
So if we end up inadvertently
doing something that is only
going to work in Cloud or
only going to work on prem,
that's something that we
feel we need to evolve past.
And the idea here is
that it isn't something
that you should hopefully have
to worry about architecting in
over time, and that's it.
ROBIN BROWN: And I think
let's close this out and then
before I do that, just
to note, all of us
will actually be at a booth with
a bunch of other Anthos SMEs
right behind this red
community corner sign.
So if you have other
questions that you
want to ask one
on one, or if you
want to continue the engagement
with professional services
or something directly with
product or engineering,
please ask us there.
But just for a close out,
how about one piece of advice
moving forward for
all these customers.
Dan, you want to start?
DAN CIRULI: Well, I
would say that as you
look on an implementation,
think about why you're doing it
and what your metric
of success is.
And if your goal is to
do more deployments--
it's a great thing to measure--
then make sure, as you go
through that implementation,
that that's the thing
you're measuring.
And you know, know what you're
trying to do going ahead.
You don't want to implement the
technology just for technology.
Understand what it is you're
trying to change and make sure
that you're tracking that.
SVEN MAWSON: I have to
think about it, too.
So I think my biggest
piece of advice
would be to really
think about what--
it's sort of what Dan
said, but think about what
you want to pay for, right?
As a developer, as
a business owner,
whatever role you have, what
parts do you want to pay for
and what parts do you want
someone else to run for you?
And I think Anthos is here for--
hopefully most of
you that realize
that yeah, you know, I don't
need to be an expert in running
hundreds of thousands
of Kubernetes clusters
or in managing encryption
keys and, you know,
handling zero day exploits
and all that kind of stuff
that we can handle
for you, right?
So think about where
you are providing value
and focus on that.
MICHAEL RUBIN: This is
way too much pressure.
One piece of advice--
listen, watch.
The community now has
gotten quite wide.
There are many people that I've
noticed that I'm engaging with.
Very rarely have I seen
a unique problem set.
And so talk to each other.
Listen to each other and
talk to us and listen to us
and realize that right
now I think the world is
making a large transition.
And as we're moving from
one environment of on prem
into cloud, again, I guess
I'm in a cliche mood today.
We really are all
doing it together.
And so what I like
a lot about multi
cloud is that we are
figuring it out all
at the same time
and the evidence
and the internet and the
support is really everywhere.
And so that's what we're
trying to provide in Anthos.
And it's why working with open
source can be so game changing.
That's it.
Thank you.
ROBIN BROWN: I think
just really quick--
I'm not supposed to say I'm
into this, but I'm going to.
I work directly with
a lot of customers.
And one thing I see
is a lot of customers
try to boil the ocean.
Don't do that.
Experiment.
Iterate.
Focus on maybe like a
CLE in your companies
that you can make those changes
and adjustments really quickly.
And then the other
thing is be vocal.
This is a fraction of
the team that's building
this product for all of you.
If a product is not serving your
use case or your business need,
be vocal with professional
services or your partners
or whoever you're working with.
And you can really pave the
way of what the product's going
to look like in the future.
So don't boil the ocean.
Experiment.
Iterate fast.
And then be vocal.
[MUSIC PLAYING]